si vemos los triángulos a bs y x y z nos
vamos a dar cuenta rápidamente que no
son congruentes de hecho tienen lados
muy diferentes y este claramente es más
pequeño que este triángulo de acá pero
si vemos con un poco más de calma hay
cosas interesantes pasando entre estos
dos triángulos una primera cosa es que
los ángulos correspondientes son
congruentes por ejemplo el ángulo acb es
congruente al ángulo x z y el ángulo c b
es congruente al ángulo zeta x y
finalmente el ángulo b a c es congruente
al ángulo y x z entonces esa es una
primera cosa interesante pero si vemos
con un poco más de cuidado los números
también nos daremos cuenta que las
razones entre lados correspondientes son
iguales
por ejemplo para pasar de este 8 a este
24 que es el lado correspondiente
tenemos que multiplicar por 3 también
para pasar de este 5 a este 15 tenemos
que multiplicar por 3 5 por 3 es igual a
15 y finalmente para pasar de este 7 al
21 también hay que multiplicar por 3
entonces podemos decir que el triángulo
abc es una versión a escala del
triángulo x z con un factor 3 vale vale
entonces aunque estos dos triángulos no
sean congruentes definitivamente hay una
relación especial entre ellos y a esa
relación especial de proporcionalidad le
llamamos semejanza no voy a poner aquí
semejanza
semejanza y la forma en la cual decimos
que dos triángulos son semejantes en
símbolos es la siguiente decimos que el
triángulo abs es semejante este es el
símbolo al triángulo y aquí hay que ser
cuidadosos con que sean los vértices
correspondientes
avan con x b b bakonyi y se va con z
entonces es semejante al triángulo x que
se está muy bien va entonces hay tres
ideas aquí importantes vale una primera
idea para pensar en semejanza es pensar
en esto de que uno es una versión la
escala del otro que ésta es una versión
miniatura de este o que ésta es una
versión agrandada de este de acá
entonces la diferencia de la congruencia
en donde sólo podíamos trasladar rotar y
voltear ahora en la semejanza también
vamos a poder aplicar escalas hacia
arriba y hacia abajo podemos expandir o
contraer la figura vale bueno entonces
lo voy a poner por acá una primera forma
de pensar en la semejanza es como una
versión a escala versión
versión a escala escala y esta escala
puede ir hacia arriba o puede ir hacia
abajo muy bien entonces de aquí nos
damos cuenta inmediatamente de algo que
la congruencia es algo más fuerte más
fuerte que la semejanza si dos
triángulos son congruentes si el
triángulo lo voy a poner por acá si el
triángulo abc es congruente al triángulo
xz y xvii cz entonces definitivamente
estos triángulos son semejantes el
triángulo abs es semejante al triángulo
x y z simplemente es una versión a
escala pero con la misma escala vale al
revés no se vale si tenemos que dos
triángulos son semejantes puede que no
sean congruentes como en este caso
porque aquí la razón de semejanza es
tres que es distinto de uno muy bien
bueno esta es una primera forma de
pensar en la semejanza pero hay otra
forma cuando estamos hablando de
triángulos que es esto de los ángulos
entonces otra forma de pensar a la
semejanza es pensando en que los ángulos
correspondientes son congruentes
y ángulos
ángulos correspondientes de los
triángulos de los triángulos son son
congruentes congruentes
entonces pues observando esta figura de
acá podemos pasar eso a símbolos vale
tenemos que dos triángulos son
semejantes o bien son una versión a
escala siempre y cuando este ángulo sea
igual a éste por ejemplo déjame ponerlo
con el color que va bueno vamos a
empezar con este verde siempre y cuando
el ángulo acb acb sea congruente al x al
ángulo ángulo x z
sé que esto es la correspondencia por la
forma en la cual escribí la semejanza
acb va con x detalle vamos con los otros
dos ángulos se ve a ángulo se vea se ve
a es congruente con el detalle x con el
ángulo z de x x y finalmente tenemos
este ángulo de acá el b hace el ángulo b
hace tiene que ser congruente al x z al
ángulo de x z
vale entonces esto de acá esta primer
forma de pensarlo y esta segunda forma
son equivalentes voy a poner una
flechitas y doble que quiere decir que
esto pasa cuando esto pasa y viceversa
bueno entonces ya tenemos dos formas de
pensar en las semejanzas vamos a una
tercera que tiene que ver con esto de
las proporciones déjame bajar un poco
entonces una tercera forma de pensar en
la semejanza es con con lados
proporcionales lo voy a poner aquí la
dos lados correspondientes
correspondientes
proporcionales proporcionales
muy bien déjame volver a pintar unos
triángulos aquí para poder hacer
referencia a ellos porque de hecho ya
estamos hablando de semejanza en general
entonces aquí tenemos el triángulo quede
un poco feo un poco más bonito si así el
abs y ese va a ser semejante a otro
triángulo xz x y z siempre y cuando los
lados correspondientes sean
proporcionales que quiere decir que sean
proporcionales bueno o sea que la razón
entre este y éste sea la misma que entre
este y éste vaya la razón entre lados
correspondientes siempre sea la misma
vale vamos a escribir eso con letras
entonces eso quería decir que este /
este o sea que éste sea una cierta
proporción de éste vamos a ponerlo así
que a b sea igual a una cierta
proporción acá
por x y x pero luego que este otro
digamos el bc sea esta misma proporción
de jay-z veces sea esa misma proporción
de jay-z ahorita pongo la cara entonces
sería acá porque éste está lo importante
es que sea la misma proporción y
finalmente vamos a pedir que este lado
sea también este lado con esta misma
proporción va es decir que sea sea el
tercer lado sea igual acá y esta misma
que cada vez es el lado correspondiente
que es zx zx una vez más sé que estos
son los lados correspondientes por la
forma en la cual escribí la semejanza de
bakol y xy bs con jay-z y hace con x z
vale bueno entonces esta es una forma de
pensarlo pero también podemos hacerlo de
otra forma podríamos dividir entre x y
aquí entre jesse está aquí y entre zx
acá y obtener lo siguiente podemos
obtener que ave ave entre xy
es igual acá
podemos obtener que veces entre jay z
veces entre entre z también es igual a
cada bandeja me poner el color amarillo
y finalmente podemos poner que se ha se
ha entre zx z x aquí este z no quedó tan
bonito pero bueno acá también es igual
es igual a que vale es igual acá y bueno
esto también se suele escribir como una
triple igualdad se suele escribir déjame
bajar un poco como que ave ave entre xy
es igual a veces entre jay-z pc / jay-z
que es igual es igual a c
en 13 está x
/ zx que es igual a acá y de aquí
podemos decir varias cosas por ejemplo
si si tenemos que el triángulo a veces
es más chiquito del que le quisiese está
entonces está acá es menor que wood si
los triángulos son congruentes entonces
son semejantes y la caja justo va a ser
igual a uno y finalmente si el triángulo
abc fuera más grande que el x7
tendríamos que acá tendría un valor
mayor que uno si vamos aquí arriba aquí
arriba el valor del acá para pasar de
abc a x y z es un tercio verdad y de
quisiese está acá es igual a tres vale
entonces ahí tenemos esos factores aquí
tenemos una forma de escribir la triple
igualdad y finalmente déjame déjame
volver a insistir en que esto de acá son
cosas equivalentes entonces aquí voy a
poner esta flechita de que son
equivalentes y esta flechita doble de
que son equivalentes vale entonces qué
sucede si los ángulos correspondientes
de un triángulo son congruentes entonces
sucede que los lados correspondientes
son proporcionales en la misma
y también sucede que uno es una versión
la escala del otro vale entonces estas
tres cosas son tres formas de pensar en
semejanza pero todas estas son
equivalentes